okay so should we get started okay so uh
quickly is gonna
talk about analysis of markov chains
using
high dimensional expanders uh okay uh
hey everyone
uh thanks for the invitation to speak um
thanks for coming um so yeah i'll be
talking about some work that uh we did
uh as we were assignments uh during the
program and then has since seen a lot of
uh
recent developments that i'm going to
talk about and this is based on several
joint works with
my collaborators nima dongchan shayan my
advisor
uh eric and cynthia
okay uh so i guess uh i would i would
summarize probably one of the
like really important themes of the
program and of the field of geometry of
polynomials is
uh saying that if you want to study say
some discrete probability distribution
mu for instance on uh the collection of
subsets of one through n
it's very fruitful to study analytic
properties so some
some kind of associate generating
polymer so
so we do this a lot for instance for
example when we look at say spanning
trees if you look at spanish trees of
this graph
you might consider the multivariate
spanning tree polynomial
um for the hardcore model or basically
the independent sets model
uh we have the sodium the associated
independence polynomial
um we also have say this also comes up
as like partition functions
of say uh various spin systems so for
example for the easing model
or for the pot small and cube colorings
and sort of an algorithmic question that
we'll be interested in is like
what kind of properties of the
polynomial will enable
allow you to obtain like uh efficient uh
sampling or counting algorithms for for
mu
okay and sort of uh you can think of you
know the polynomial in sort of
several different ways one in terms of
as a list of coefficients you can think
of as a function
but one way that's been sort of been
very fruitful is
uh thinking like uh studying the roots
of a polynomial so
and sort of it's been kind of uh
it's been observed that basically
roughly speaking whenever you have some
kind of a root free region
for an associated generating polynomial
you can expect a computational
tractability for your accounting or
sampling problem
uh for instance using uh the barbaranach
polynomial interpolation method that was
talked about yesterday
so for instance for spanning trees we
know
that the associated multivariate
spanning tree polynomial is real stable
uh just by using say the matrix tree
theorem
um oh okay so for span trees we don't
actually need to use part
you know polynomial interpolation to do
the counting and sampling because it has
a determinant representation
but for the next three applications
sort of a recent line of algorithmic
work has
tried to use interpolation to obtain
accounting sampling algorithms so for
instance for the hardcore model
we have some nice zero-free regions
uh displayed here this is a figure that
i
uh copied from a paper by harvey or
truvastava and vondrag
and we have sort of like like the
classic uh liang theorem
for the zeros of the easing partition
function when you think of this function
as a polynomial in x
and then also there's some work done by
fischer in 65
that studies the zeros of this function
when you view it as a polynomial beta
for fixed x
and then also uh yesterday uh pew she
was
uh spoke about a recent result on zero
regions for the pots model basically
they show that there's a neighborhood
around the interval zero 1 for which
this polynomial in z has no zeros
okay but sort of uh
one main i would say one main drawback
of
the interpolation method and sort of the
closely related correlation decay method
is that typically you only get a
polynomial time or like efficient
algorithms
if you assume some kind of bounded
degree so like basically all these
problems here they're
problems on graphs and uh basically all
except
okay so besides spanish trees where you
don't need polynomial interpolation
these are three methods
and sorry these are three problems if
you use interpolation you
you uh typically only get efficient
algorithms if you assume
bounded degrees of the graph and this
seems
kind of inherent to the algorithm and
not just to the analysis itself
okay so that's one main drawback
although these these methods have do
have the advantage that they're actually
completely deterministic
okay uh so historically there was a
uh another uh uh
sort of kind of excuse me can i ask one
question
is it only bounded degree or is it the
fact that all degrees
have to be more or less the same or the
same so for example if all degrees are
very large
but the same i think it's
bound to degree i mean they don't need
uh typically
the reason you need bound agreements is
that there's some kind of
brute forcing in the algorithm and then
you you want to sort of you know
truncate the error
sort of restrict your attention to only
you know a small number of
say subgraphs or objects and there you
only need boundary degrees it's not
necessarily like a regularity yes yes
yes that i know but if
all degrees are you know large but this
you know if all degrees are say 2 to
the square root of n you know you can
still do uniform sampling
the importance for the algorithms is
that you don't have huge variances
in the degrees oh
okay i i guess i didn't know that but uh
i thought
i thought bobby knocks method doesn't
work that way right
as far as i know uh which way but barbie
not method like you typically want to
look at
coefficients of these polynomials the
first few coefficients
right but you have to do some kind of
enumeration for that right like yeah
exactly
numerator bounded degree if you have
a huge degree then there is no local
neighborhood you have to figure out
these quantities which
okay that makes sense thank you thank
you thank you sorry thank you thank you
oh yeah thanks for that yeah and thanks
for the question too
um uh right so
i'm sorry so yeah so i'm saying so like
historically there's another
class of algorithms that sort of
preceded collision decay and
interpolation which is markov chain
monte carlo
and let me sort illustrate uh sort of a
quick comparison of
the state-of-the-art previously for
market tree multi-color compared to
interpolation correlation okay
i'm going to illustrate it for just the
hardcore model because it's easy to do
so
okay so for hardcore model so so
remember a hardcore model
is this model here which is a
distribution over independent sets of
graph and you're weighting
each independent set by lambda to some
parameter lambda to the size
okay and so it's well known that there's
actually this like phase transition
point for which
below this phase transition point when
lambda is below this critical threshold
you can expect to have you can have fb
tasks based off
of the famous correlation decay
algorithm pioneered by whites
and also recently by interpolation due
to like
peter's rex and patel rex using the
barbados approach
and it's also known that above this
critical threshold basically you cannot
hope to have any kind of efficient
approximation algorithm
okay okay so this is like so
so these algorithms are based on
correlation decay or interpolation
so not see what was known for markov
chain monte carlo
so this was studied actually in very
early on in the late
90s by lubia pagoda where they showed
that for lambda below 1 over delta minus
3 the
delta here is the maximum degree of the
graph for lambda below this threshold
you can get the markov chain mixes so
you get an efficient algorithm using
markov chain
and sort of uh the reason that one
reason also markov chain is very nice
and people say this is because markov
chain 10
markup chains tend to have uh very fast
running times so like
and i'll talk i'll talk a little bit
more about this in a bit
so sort of several substance subsequent
works by lubia pagoda
dyer and green hill and also by pagoda
improve this threshold to 2 over delta
knights 2.
um but since then uh uh so
where after these works the question
remains how do you get all the way up to
the critical threshold so this critical
pressure was known for a while
um and they could the field we could get
up to this critical threshold typically
assuming some additional structure of
the graph you have
some pretty restrictive assumptions so
for instance you would need
either some kind of large degree
assumption or like large girth
assumption
or even like some kind of immutability
assumption so like
where the uh the size of the balls of
the graph
are not growing too fast okay
um and so okay so this is a
so i remember yesterday when fuchsia was
talking about colorings uh one of those
really cool aspects
or outcomes of their work was that um
uh so previously there was this
algorithm for sampling colorings
when queues larger than two delta uh
using markup genomic color and their
work show
gave a deterministic algorithm based on
interpolation that matches this bound so
they show that they close this gap
between deterministic
and randomized algorithms but sort of
here
we kind of have like the opposite
situation so here it was like we knew
we know we knew there was like uh
deterministic algorithms
based on correlation carrier
interpolation that could get all the way
up to this critical threshold
uh for uh arbitrary for uh boundary
graphs but you don't need to assume
additional structure like
large girth or like immutability whereas
somehow a markov chain monte carlo
a black behind like you can only get up
to say two over delta minus two
um for boundary graphs but uh sort of
being here you have to start making
extra assumptions
so recently we managed to close close
this gap
um so enjoying work with nema and
cheyenne and also in a follow-up work
with zhongchan and eric we showed that
some some markup chain called the some
very natural and simple markup chain
called the global dynamics
uh actually mixes rapidly for uh all
any two-spin system in the so-called
correlation decay machine
okay so this basically essentially
matches all the known results
of at least for two spin systems sorry
at least for two spin systems
uh for correlation decay and
interpolation
okay and then there's also some follow
work work which
also get this the same result but for uh
cue colorings on triangle for your graph
so this was also
not known before by mcmc uh the work
of pyush and jing chong ngu and alistair
sinclair
uh managed to get themselves itself
forward using interpolation
okay um
i guess i should i should mention that
so uh at the moment uh so the running
time improvement
um so i guess one advantage of this
markup chain approach as i mentioned
earlier is that actually you don't need
to assume boundary degrees actually so
you can get an algorithm that depends so
delta here is like
say the gap from how close you are to
criticality
and uh you can get an algorithm with
running type was exponent does not
depend on say
the maximum degree as opposed to uh
these interpolation or correlation of k
approaches although i guess you could
say that okay this
this running time still isn't accurate
and it's
but uh it's still some improvement
okay and so i guess i'll be talking
about mainly these two results
and roughly sketching how they were
achieved
okay and so uh basically the rough idea
here is that there's this notion of high
dimensional expansion which somehow
manages to
sort of connect local properties of the
distribution with
the global properties of the
distribution and
so this look uh and i'll sort of give
some uh
more intuitions about this later in the
talk um
uh but sort of this kind of local global
behavior sort of somehow manages to
overcome a lot of the barriers that
previous markup chain techniques
ran into and let me just mention briefly
that these local global properties are
useful not just for like
studying random walks but also for other
major fields and
subfields of tcs such as pcp's property
testing
uh boolean function analysis and
constraint satisfaction problems and
then also to uh error correcting codes
okay so okay the rough outline of the
rest of my talk is just i'm gonna
start describing sort of the markup
chain that we're going to use and
uh in general full generality this is
known as the high order walk which was
first defined by kaufman and kaufman and
mass in 2016 and this was also talked by
also the subject of the dot's talk
yesterday
and then i'll proceed to talk about high
dimensional expansion and how you can
kind of think of it as like a
going beyond lock on cavity in some
sense and i'll make this more precise in
a bit
and then finally i'll talk about how we
can use
now use correlation decay to analyze
high dimensional expansion and then i'll
conclude with some future directions
okay so any questions so far
okay so okay so let me let me talk about
the high water like oh right now block
right now so this is the
you know the market machine that we're
going to use to solve these sampling and
counting problems
uh so i said this this was first i think
to find a work by coffin and mass
and i'm going to illustrate this higher
to walk by looking
at stable sets of this small three
vertex graph here okay
and throughout the talk i'm going to use
uh green to denote uh
like excel and i think of stable sets
it's like coloring the vertices of the
graph
green and red such that the collection
of green vertices
is a stable set so no pair of vertices
that are color green
are connected by an edge okay
so here i've enumerated all the stable
sets of this graph so
you can have no vertices in your stable
set you have one of the vertex so you
have these two vertices here
okay uh and okay i'm going to construct
this random walk i'm going to try to
relate this to an associated generating
polynomial okay so you can
for this distribution over stable sets
you can also see the following
homogeneous multiplying polynomial
which is i'm going to get a variable for
each vertex color pair
and the bar here is going to also
indicate that the vertex is out
so red and the bar means vertex is out
and then green means the vertex is in
so here i'm going to have x1 x2 x3 bar
all bar because these vertices are all
out and then here
for instance i have x1 in green because
the vertex is green
and so on okay and as before as in the
hardcore model i'm going to i'm going to
weight each independent set
by lambda to the size of the independent
set so i'm going to give that a
coefficient
a corresponding coefficient in this
polynomial
okay so i have this problem i just add
up all these monomials so you know
you'll notice that okay so this
polynomial
is homogeneous of degree being the
number of vertices of the graph
it's multi-fine so there are no all the
monomials are square free
and each monomial is in the monomials
are one-to-one correspondence with
the stable sets okay and
let me just mention also that this
construction of
some this polynomial actually works out
you can do this for any kind of
say two-spin system or q-spin system or
anything like that
okay so uh so okay so i have all these
stable sets and have a corresponding
polynomial so now i'm going to tell you
about
sort of so the random walk okay and so
the random walk
sort of does like a kind of down-up
motion okay um
i'll be pretty more precise what this
means so let me just like show you a
simulation of this walk
so let's say i started uh this stable
set
this random walk is on stable sets so
all or in other words the monomials
of this polynomial here
so okay so let's say start here i look
at
i pick around i look at
partial assignments of partial colorings
of the graph where i
just like uncolor one of these vertices
at random okay
and i move there let's say i pick one of
them at random okay so
so basically this in this step i am uh
uncoloring a uniformly random vertex of
the current stable set and then to move
back to a stable set
i look at all possible completions of
this partial coloring into a full color
so in this case i can
i have two options i can make this red
again so i can move back to where i came
from
or i can make this green i can move here
and then i'll move
i'll move to the corresponding stable
set with probability proportional to its
coefficient so here
i'm going to move to this with this
stable set with probability
lambda over one plus lambda
and i'm going to move to this stable set
with probability one
over one plus lambda okay just
i pick one of those at random okay and
then this process just continues
okay
so in words you can express this random
walk it's just saying i pick a uniform
vertex at random
i uncolor it and then i basically
essentially re-sample the color for that
vertex okay
and so this this this particular
dynamics for this
this particular distribution this
particular model the hardware model
has the name is called the global
dynamics and it's a
very extensively studied a markov chain
in the literature
but let me say that this sort of
construction of like some of this higher
order work
you can actually do it for any
homogeneous
multifine polynomial with non-negative
coefficients okay
and so this is sort of like a general
recipe for constructing a
markov chain to do the sampling and
which also recovers some of the very
famous
markov chains that have been studied in
the literature so for instance this not
only covers
recovers the global dynamics but in the
context of metroids this also recovers
the basis exchange walk
i think this was a first study by
mikhail mazarani
okay okay so throughout the stock i'm
just going to
let p of down up so i guess first are
there any questions about like
how this high order walk works
okay so uh throughout the talk i'm going
to write p
of down up to be to know that the
transition probability matrix of this
random walk
and sort of the main goal we'll be
concerned with is
how can you up or bound the second
largest eigenvalue of p up down up away
from one
so it's well known that if you can do
this if you can buffer down the second
eigenvalue then this will imply
some concrete uh mixing time for this
random walk or
yeah okay and
sort of a really question is like under
what conditions on this polynomial can
you
ensure ensure that this economic value
is bounded
okay so okay so that essentially
concludes
uh the at least defining what the higher
what what the markup chain will be
studying is okay okay
so now let's talk about high dimensional
expansion and basically this is an
answer
one possible answer to the question of
under what conditions on gmu
uh does can you bear on the second
largest eigenvalue
okay so uh it's called high dimensional
expansion and one way to think about it
is beyond lock on cavity it's going
beyond lock concavity so
uh to go beyond locking cavity i need to
first tell you what log cavity is
so we say so it turns out
okay so first uh polynomial is lock
concave
if the test times logarithm is negative
sign by definite
but it turns out that you can this is
actually equivalent to just saying that
uh the second largest eigenvalue of a
testing is bounded by zero
okay so uh this is also mentioned in i
think chris talked earlier today
and uh now that we can strengthen
block concavity and this was done by
gerbert since 2006 and also in very
recent works by inari of viscaran
vincent and then also by
brendan and her uh
so a gerber it's called the stronghold
concave basically it says that
not only do you want the polynomial to
be lock concave but you also want all
partial derivatives to be lock concave
okay um i guess in an arrow basically on
benzene they call it
completely low concave and then brenden
huh they call it
lorenzine okay
so why vlogging can block concavity
interesting so one reason
at least from the sampling and counting
perspective is that uh it turns out
in recent work um we managed to show
that if
this panel is strong locking cave then
this
down up walk has a nice bound on its
spectral gap and in particular implies a
very nice mixing time
and this has since been brought down to
the tight
r-log r i'm missing uh from recent works
by kran guamusa and
anari liu and obese garan and vincent
uh okay so
i want to think of lock and cavity as
some kind of expansion so sort of this
this talk is about high dimensional
expansion so
so where is this expansion so so okay so
we have locking cavity saying that
second largest eigenvalue of the hessian
is bounded by a zero
and i'm going to interpret this testing
as being the adjacency matrix of some
graph
okay so in particular this graph is
going to have vertices corresponding to
the variables of this polynomial
and i'm going to connect x i and xj with
an edge of weight
being the partial the corresponding
partial the corresponding entry
uh in the hessian okay i guess
throughout the talking
this is all going to everything's going
to be evaluated all once so
yeah just think of this as being
evaluating this polynomial once
okay so this is some weighted edge and
this will give you some weighted graph
here
whose corresponding adjacency matrix is
exactly this test scene
okay now it turns out basically
if you have this condition of the second
eigenvalue of the hessian being bounded
by zero
this is equivalent to saying that the
transition matrix
the random walk matrix of this weighted
graph has a large spectrograph a very
large spectral graph so it's at least
one
so typically when you think of expander
graphs you think of
uh spectral graph being at least some
constant like a quarter or something but
here we actually have its bounded is at
least one which is
basically the best you can ever hope for
this is an unbelievably good
standard okay
uh i guess just for reference you can
also write down
this transition matrix in this form
just for concreteness if you're
interested
but in any case uh
such strong expansion we know it
actually only holds for matrix
essentially matrix-like objects so
you can't really hope this for such a
thing in general
okay so we want to go but you kind of
expect that if
you know maybe you don't have maybe your
polynomial is not
exactly like on k but it's sort of
approximately concave that maybe you can
still
do the sampling okay um
right and so you can you can formalize
as follows okay you can say
say gmu is like you can't think of it as
approximately lock concave
if it's the second eigenvalue of this
hessium
but okay so tilde is always going to
mean the hessian is normalized so
normalized in the sense of
looking at the random walk matrix the
random walk version of the hessian
okay so you can think of this polynomial
as being approximately
concave if say the the
second eigenvalue of the normalized
testing
is bounded by some value alpha okay so
log concavity is just alpha being zero
okay um
and just as an aside you can think of uh
it turns out that you know this
approximate lock on cavity condition is
actually equivalent to
true lock concavity of
the polynomial after composition with
raising each variable to some power
alpha
okay okay
uh so okay so let's first see let me
let's see an example where you have
sort of some positive value here okay so
let's look at
stable sets of this small two vertex
graph where these two vertices are
connected by an edge
okay so
uh so here are the stable sets and then
they have the corresponding weight
lambda
1 and lambda and the corresponding
generating polynomial here is going to
be x 1 bar x 2 bar which is
for this stable set x 1 x 2 bar for this
table set and x 1 bar x2 for this stable
set here with the corresponding
coefficients
okay now you can compute what the
hessian looks like here and
i'm not going to give you the hessian
i'm just going to draw the graph okay so
the graph here is going to have
so vertices corresponding to the
variables so there are four vertices
and then we have edges connecting pairs
or variables whenever we have a
corresponding non-zero entry in the
hessian or basically for each monomial
in this case since it's degree two we
have an edge corresponding to each
monomial
of this generating polynomial
so for instance connecting x1 x2 bar we
have lambda
and so on okay okay so basically this
thing looks like a path
and uh you kind of expect me it's
since only only on four vertices maybe
it's uh you know kind of a quote-unquote
expander just because
you'll have a constant number of
vertices but it's definitely not that
good
like as good as you know taking alpha b0
and indeed you can
if you compute the second eigenvalue of
the random walk for this graph this
weighted graph
you'll get that is equal to lambda which
is strictly positive and some constant
okay so we would say like for instance
for instance that this
this polynomial here is kind of like
approximately lock okay
if for instance if lambda is small
okay all right so just as we did with
lock and cavity we can strengthen
this sort of approximately cavity but uh
now
um we call it local spectral expansion
and this name
derives so it comes from the high
dimensional expansion community where
um typically all these things are
phrased in the language of simplicial
complexes but
for this talk you can phrase everything
equivalently as
in terms of polynomials okay so we'll
say it's a
let's say this polynomial is a local
spectral expander if
you can have a nice second eigenvalue
bound for the normalized test scene of
all the derivatives
of the polynomial okay and this was
studied in
some works recent works by dinora
kaufman openheim and kaufman and
openheim
okay so just as in uh
in the case of log concavity where you
can get mixing
and get a good sampling algorithm uh
what you kind of want to say is that if
you have
a local spectral expansion with some
good parameters alpha zero up to alpha n
minus two
then you can get mixing and that's
indeed what uh vidat and lakshi showed
and that's what you would without
talking about yesterday which is that if
you have local spectral expansion then
you can get some very concrete
uh second eigenvalue bound for
the down-up walk that you care about in
the end
okay and basically what we do in this
reason works is that
we sort of fill in uh the other side of
things
we we show that these alpha k's can be
bounded nicely
like one over n minus k okay for
at least for two spin systems in the
correlation decay regime and then these
two results combined
imply the main
result on sampling which is that the
global dynamics mixes rapidly
and this is also the same strategy that
these recent works for colorings also
goes through they show that you know in
this regime
you can get a nice bound on these uh
parameters alpha k
okay and okay let me just sort of
conclude this this part of the topic is
just saying
summarizing the rough strategy here
which is that you have some kind of
local global theorem
which is uh what's uh fidel naturally
proved
and what's left to do is typically to
prove some
prove this local spectral expansion and
then once you have these two things
you can deduce rapid mixing for your
chain
okay so basically that concludes like
the second part uh
any questions about you know high
dimensional expansion local spectral
expansion
or anything like that
okay okay so now let me tell you about
correlation decay and how you can use it
to reduce expansion
okay uh
sorry how much time do i have right now
like 20 minutes 20 minutes okay sure
okay all right so i'm gonna tell you how
to get uh sort of some
techniques for getting expansion okay
um okay so let me first tell you
uh sort of some what was previously
known uh
or like the techniques that were
previously used and sort of the main
result in this area is this uh nice
trickle-down theorem of
openhype okay and basically what it says
is the following
if if you know that
the hessian of the derivative of g mu
has some
nice eigenvalue bound then you can
actually deduce
an eigenvalue bound for the hessian of
gmu itself
okay so
sorry right so just just
for example if you if you specialize is
the case
where you have law concave so you have
that
uh the derivatives of g mu
have hessian having a second eigenvalue
bounded by zero
then you actually know that g mu itself
has a second eigenvalue
of its test and bounded by zero okay so
basically this is
another way to say is that log concavity
of all derivatives of g mu
implies log and cavity of g mu itself
okay and so this
really works beautifully very
beautifully for metroids because this
kind of
result says that okay uh this is
actually exactly
the uh uh the reason
uh why um you know in the in the
definition of say lorentzian polynomials
that chris sword talked about this
morning
you only have to consider
a polynomial that you can get from
differentiating g mu down to
quadratic polynomials okay but that's
just an inside
uh but in any case so this kind of
result has worked really beautifully for
metroids
but sort of as we said earlier
such strong expansion when you have zero
here
really only works out for matrix but not
for
say for example stable sets of a graph
or other say spin systems
okay so okay and uh
so let me just be a little more concrete
of why this trickling down fails
for say stable sets okay so let's look
at say stable sets
of this two vertex graph again so as we
as we did earlier um as we showed
earlier so we have like the stable sets
of this
uh so okay sorry so we have this
generating polynomial here
and a generic polynomial gives this
weighted graph from its hessian
and uh as we said earlier the second
eigenvalue
of the normalization of this hessian is
equal to lambda which is some
let's think of it as like some constant
okay
now the issue is that uh so this bound
here you should notice that it's
actually deteriorating in lambda
all right sorry deteriorating in alpha
so you know if you say start at a
constant
alpha here then after say alpha many uh
sort of some constant number of
iterations
this down here is going to become
essentially useless
okay so we sort of have to go uh
yeah uh start yeah so
right so so let me just summarize like
sort of the rough pattern
that trickling down needs which is that
you need these alpha d minus two
to be bounded by say order one over d
and only then
can you deduce a nice eigenvalue bounce
for
alpha d minus three and so on but what
typically happens
empirically and also what we managed to
prove is that typically you have
one half like some constant at the top
and then
it actually improves as you go down okay
can i ask a question do you mean the
specific proof method
fails or that the underlying structures
are not expanders probably sorry what i
mean is that this proof method using
this trickle-down theorem fails
but you can actually get expansion using
other methods which is why
excellent thank you thank you thank you
okay
yeah thanks for the question yeah so
basically uh the point is
to all this says that so this trickling
down theorem is very nice it's actually
used extensively in the high dimensional
extension
community um it's it's useful for a lot
of other applications but
for the specific sampling applications
that i'm talking about here
what i'm saying is that this proof
method is not will not work
so what we're going to do is um we're
going to
uh so sort of the plan of the rest of
the talk is to
show how using the correlation decay
method we can actually
uh prove the expansion of these
polynomials okay uh and so
to do that let me let's first like sort
of discuss
what uh these
i'm going to sort of write down the
entries of this random walk matrix in a
sort of a nicer form
okay so the first claim is that
you can actually write down the entries
of this normalized
hessian as essentially up to some one
over d
factor being the conditional marginals
marginals of a variable condition on say
some other variable
okay basically the idea here the
intuition is that if you look at
say this edge and you look at
this two partial derivatives if you
divide by the polynomial itself you get
exactly the probability
of i and j and similarly if you look at
just say a single partial derivative
with vector i
and you divide by the polynomial itself
you get
the marginal of i itself
okay and so if you sort of put these two
together you can kind of see that okay
if you divided
this by this then you will get exactly
this
conditional marginal okay and then this
one over d
is more like a normalization factor okay
but sort of the main uh main option of
this is that
you can from this you can show
that you can upper bound the second
largest eigenvalue
of these normalized testings by
this kind of influence like quantity
here okay
so this is like an influence in the
sense that
you're looking at how the conditioning
the status
of say a vertex r affects the status of
the marginals of another vertex v
okay so okay sorry so actually this is a
little bit of typo but this is the same
normalization that comes from here
and then this is like a total influence
of a vertex r
okay and sort of
all that's left to do is really to
basically what you want to do is really
bound the summation of influences
okay and so for instance if you've seen
like these uh you know the works on
uh like uh works by debrucian and his
co-authors like
schlossman um where they say
they so they work with like a similar
notion of influence
and using this notion of influence they
can do this rapid mixing using
techniques such as path coupling here
it's very similar
except now we really have kind of uh
you know we have like an exponential
family like a exponentially large
ensemble of matrices for which we have
to bounce the second eigenvalue so we
have
analyzed the influence over let's see
all conditional distributions of mu as
well
okay but this is actually this is a very
related or very similar quantity to the
one studied by
uh depression
okay okay sorry and let me also say that
you should kind of think of uh just a
little more intuition you can kind of
think of this influence as also
measuring
uh how far your distribution mu is from
being a product distribution right
so for instance if mu really was a
product distribution
then whether or not the status of r does
not affect the status v at all
and so this difference is zero okay so
this this precisely captures the fact
that if you have a product distribution
um this uh
this thing is zero okay and so
if this thing is small then you're kind
of saying that mu is also like close to
a product distribution in some
sense
okay uh any any questions so far about
influences and its relation to
eigenvalues
okay good so sort of our goal now is to
bound this total influence for all
vertices are in our graph
and i'm going to sort of sketch this
using the correlation decay method okay
so what coefficient k or spatial mixing
says is that essentially this
this influence here should be bounded by
something that is exponentially small in
the distance right so the farther
essentially
the point is that the farther away your
vertices are from each other
uh the more weakly correlated they are
right so if they're right next to each
other
for instance if they're right next to
each other and i declare this vertex to
be
in the independent set then that forces
the status
of the other of the neighboring vertex
to be out right whereas if
there whereas if they are very far what
you intuitively want to say is that
it doesn't really matter what you
condition this vertex
to be like in or out it doesn't really
affect
the status of this vertex okay so that's
kind of like the intuition kind of
spatial mixing
okay and you can show that in sort of in
a very black box manner
spatial mixing at least for minimal
graphs implies an order one upper bound
for this total influence
okay basically just the reason is that
if your
influences are decaying exponentially
fast but
the size of the balls of your graph are
growing only polynomially fast or
sub-exponentially fast
then you can write down say some
convergence
series and get some order one upper
bound
okay i'm not gonna dwell on this point
too much but
basically this the point of this is that
okay you can deduce in a black box
fashion
um that's spatial mixing or correlation
decay
implies a nice upper bound on this total
influence
and this is actually also known using
other techniques i think uh due to the
abrusion
and others that for immutable graphs
spatial mixing
and mixing up the global dynamics are
very intimately connected um but this is
like another way to see that
okay so okay but we want to go beyond
the meanwhile
minimal graphs right so what we do is uh
what you can do is you can so open up
the analysis of how you get spatial
mixing in the first place
okay and so you uh
so the proof strategy is basically to
reduce this problem to a problem
injuries and then use some
known correlation k analysis to to
analyze this in a more refined
manner okay
okay okay so the first step is a
reduction to trees
and basically roughly speaking the claim
is that you can
to bound this total influence it
suffices to bound the total influence
of the root in the associated
self-avoiding walk
tree okay
so i'm not i'm going to just give like a
very very
brief high-level sketch of the proof
but sort of intuitively i guess
what happens is that you can kind of
follow the original proof of bytes which
shows that
the marginals of vertex are preserved
when you go to the saatchi
representation
and you can uh
okay so okay so maybe let's let's let me
uh go just a little bit more detail so
i want to look at say the vertex the
influence of this vertex r
on another vertex v okay so one nice
trick you can do is you can sort of
split this vertex
and then look at sort of like a
telescoping sum
okay where you condition all these
vertices to be
out you look at the influence of this
vertex on v then you condition this
vertex to be in
and you look at the influence of this
vertex on v and so on
and if you sort of do this inductively
following the same proof by weights for
his results on the self-avoiding walk
tree
you can essentially prove this i don't
want to spend too much more details but
essentially this this part is
roughly speaking can be done using
standard techniques
okay so at this point we just have to
bound
this total influence for
a tree so the total influence of a
vertex of the root
on all other vertices in the tree and
sort of a nice observation here is that
in a tree you can use conditional
independence to factor this influence
as the product over influences over
edges so for instance
basically the point here is that if i
have this tree i have a root i'm looking
at the influence of
r on this vertex v and let's say u is
say
a descendant of r and it's an ancestor
of v
okay then basically what i'm saying here
is that the influence
of r on v is equal to the product of the
influence of
r onto u and the influence of u onto v
okay so this is like a nice
factorization property
okay and so as an immediate corollary
you can you can prove
that you know okay so then what what
we're really saying is that you know
along
this path from r to v the influence
of r on v factors as a product over
the influences of all the edges along
all the edges
of this path okay
and then from this you can prove uh that
this total influence is bounded by some
nice quantity depending on lambda
times to the power of the distance
between r and v
so this is this is very much like the
correlation decay
statement okay
um
right so i guess i guess let me say that
the reason is lambda over lambda one
plus lambda here is it because you can
bound these marginals by
and over one plus lambda i'm not going
to get into too much detail there
okay but so armed with this
okay so once you have this and let me
say that this bound here is actually
also tight for a certain example so for
the path where you have uh just
there's no branching at all it's just a
path of vertices
this bound here is actually tight okay
now we're looking at say boundary degree
graphs let's say a maximum degree delta
graph
and so there can be say almost there can
be like
order delta to the t many vertices at
distance t in the worst case
right and so if you sort of plug this
this bound in
with this observation then you can uh
say that this sum here is bounded by
order of one
whenever lambda is a mos one over delta
maximum degree minus one
okay um now this is not exactly the
critical threshold that we were aiming
for
um but so the the the way to sort of
think about how you can actually improve
this
this condition here is by the fact that
you know
this bound is tight for a path but a
path should not
definitely not have this many vertices
at distance t
away so there's kind of uh you know
some trade-off here right
so you can improve this by sort of
amortizing
this bound over all levels of the tree
and it's gonna sort of
very roughly sketch this here so
basically what you can prove is that in
the correlation decay regime
if you look at total influence of the
root
on all vertices at a given level
this decays uh as you
increase the distance okay and if you
if you if you can show this then this
implies an
order one upper bound uh on your total
influence
okay and i'm not gonna go into detail
this this
this analysis here can be quite involved
but um
yeah all right
okay so but so let me conclude by sort
of like summarizing like the strategy
that we took here which is that so we
have some kind of local global theorem
and then
you want to prove some kind of high
dimensional expansion or local spectral
expansion and then with these two
you can deduce rapid mixing and what we
showed the way i sort of
mentioned this talk is that you can
prove high dimensional expansion using
techniques such as the triple down
theorem by openheim
you can use the correlation decay method
which is what i just mentioned
uh you can this question k method is
also very related to
the geometry of polynomials uh you can
use hodge theory which is what we used
for
the law concave uh in the case of lock
and key polynomials
um but uh you know there could be many
other
techniques there there are many other
techniques that we don't
possible techniques to get high
dimensional expansion which we don't
know about it
okay good so so let me conclude with
just some open problems so
naturally i mean you can uh there's
uh the question of using this for
new sampling applications so uh beyond
say two spin systems or for colorings
and triangle-free graphs
for instance could you potentially use
this to get uh
you know colorings uh sampling queue
colorings
for q at least delta plus two that's
like one of the major open problems of
the field
uh can get new methods to certify
expansion which is what i sort of
alluded to earlier on the previous slide
can use can you have new methods to
certify expand high dimensional
expansion
as i mentioned earlier the the running
time of the current algorithms based off
this approach
have not been that great
um uh they're definitely not like some
fixed polynomial
which is what you would definitely like
uh
so that's also one future approach uh
future direction
um and sort of towards this you know can
you get say
refinements of the current known local
global results or could you guess a
modified logarithmic solar limiting
qualities
like in the way that crian guamusa did
for
block concave distributions
and then uh i guess there are sort of
two other more
open-ended questions which is can you
use these to analyze
markov chains besides simple ones like
larger dynamics
so for instance there was this very
recent work but don't join eric and
blanca and i'm forgetting some
other authors which at least taking some
of the techniques inspired by the high
dimensional expansion method
managed to analyze the swenson wong
dynamics on trees
okay i don't know too much about that
work but uh that's definitely this is a
i think it's a nice
uh research direction and then also
um other applications beyond sampling so
for instance maybe to
some kind of optimization there was some
work by vidat and lapt
and geronimo which uh fernando
geronimo which uses high dimensional
expansion to study
constraint satisfaction problems so
i mean that's i guess that's kind of it
towards this but uh i think this is also
a nice open-ended
research direction uh yeah so i'll stop
here thanks
thanks lot quickly really nice talk any
questions
so i'll ask one uh nice talk quickly um
do you so for the zero local expanders
uh zero local spectral expanders we have
this nice combinatorial structure coming
from
metroids or polymetroids is it
um sort of understood at all what sorts
of combinatorial structures
show up in these more general local
spectral expanders
uh so what do you mean by combinatorial
structures do you mean like the fact
that
these things are like complete
multi-party graphs or
uh well what sort of supports the
polynomials or distributions
can have okay she's asking for a newton
positive like
how could it look like i see
yeah i guess like one special case of
like
some of these polymers that we studied
in this case were
um for example like these stable set
polytopes
um so i don't know too many properties
of that but
um to be honest i'm
not sure okay uh
maybe i give one comment i think there
is one difference between that one
big difference between
sort of this regime of counting and
sampling problems
so so here we're typically dealing with
objects which are exponentially large
support
in the ground set of elements and that
that is
the regime of applications that we have
seen uh but there is other group of
people who study
actual ramanujan complexes and ramanujan
high dimensional expanders those are
those are very sparse
those have like support which is a
linear in the number of ground elements
so it's like it's like having you cannot
have a mesoderm you cannot have a matrix
which has linearly many bases in the
number of ground elements
so uh so it follows from lock concavity
that you cannot have such a small
support so if you have zero local
spectral expansion you cannot have
such a small support but it turns out
that once you allow
this approximate lock cavity you can
have that
that small support but be very different
but yeah so it could be actually very
different like even
but but i think on the other hand i
think it's very
so there are lots of people working on
finding combinatorial constructions of
these ramanujan graphs
and it's not so there are some
algebraic constructions but there are
usually
hard to understand so i think that's one
avenue which could be
interesting to explore for our community
to see if you can use polynomial subella
and to better understand
high dimensional expanders like sparks
high dimensional expanders that
ramanujan ones
yeah are there lower bounds on these
locals on these spectral gaps at
different levels
in terms of data like about the degrees
in some sense in terms of sorry beta
i mean could you prove that you cannot
have so you said you can't have a zero
local spectral expander
uh unless it has a certain degree
basically right
uh i'm sure i'm asking if there's like
something like an
orphana type bound proving that the kth
spectral gap has to be at least at most
something
if you have at most such and such number
of at least as a function of a support
you're asking well i don't know what the
right question is you could look at the
up degree
or the support or i don't know you know
some parameter like that but
to really codify that there's you
shouldn't hope to get one over d at all
the levels
in these applications for city type
reason
at least for the kind of sampling
problems that we're studying here i
don't know of any such result but there
is a related result for
at least in the sparse uh regime that
shannon just mentioned
uh there was this result i think in
stock of last year
where they study a graph a regular graph
which is an expander
but also such that all neighbor if you
look at the neighborhood of a vertex
and you restricted that that's also a
regular graph and it's also an expander
they study those those kinds of graphs
and that you can think of as being like
say a two dimensional
or like a some kind of high dimensional
expander
and they prove some kind of a lombarpana
theorem for that case
but uh i don't remember the exact
details of that
if you want i can point you to the
baseball palette and uh
yeah lineal and chapman lineal yeah you
can take a look
but that's the only thing i've seen too
so i mean i guess i'm wondering if
there's some high level reason why in
this independence complex
why i mean why you should not expect the
gaps to be one over d
at all the levels like can you easily
see that actually the gaps have to be
like you know half at the top and then
not the gaps the second eigenvalue
has to be not very good at the top and
then maybe gets better as you go lower
i mean i guess for the the reason that
there's one simple reason why this the
gaps are like
bad at the top which is just that
typically at the top your gaps
i mean the the these graphs there's low
crafts yeah they're only on like
constant many vertices so if it's not
the second leg is not zero it's it's
like some constant at least
right um
well they're weights too right but yeah
yeah but typically the weights are like
controlled to be like
a constant as well right like yeah um
uh i mean i guess there are some
examples that you can construct where
uh the the
[Music]
uh the gaps
uh don't improve as you go
as you sort of differentiate um
where it's kind of like in order to get
a good uh
a good bound on the mixing time you
really have to like you know impose just
like
you know that these parameters lambda
are smaller like at least for
hardcore um but yeah maybe
yeah maybe that's a discussion for
offline i mean there are some other
reasons right for example
even in this hardcore model uh
when you look at the top level like as
quickly said
the top eigenvalue is lambda but
we know if lambda is beyond the
threshold the markov chain doesn't mix
if you make lambda a little bit bigger
at the threshold you don't change the
top eigenvalue of this matrix
it remains it's still lambda okay so
something else has to go wrong somewhere
else yeah exactly
yeah and are there inequalities between
the gaps at different levels
like in some generality that if you know
i don't know like
if you know some of the gaps can you get
so many qualities on the other gaps
or is it you can construct examples with
really wild
behavior of gaps
[Music]
i mean
uh so i mean besides this like trickle
down theorem by openheim
um the gaps can be i think they can vary
pretty
wildly in a given level so like you can
have for instance
uh sometimes even on like a fixed level
like
most of the gaps are one they're huge
like the best possible
but then some of them are like you know
only like a constant like say
i was more wondering but like relation
between the worst gap at different
levels
but uh oh which is like what the
trickling down theorem says but
in one i was wondering if there are more
things like that that you
even have intuition about let's i mean i
don't know oh
one thing i think it's true is that
freaking trickling down theorem
says that it doesn't go up too much yeah
i think you can also say it doesn't go
down too much oh really you so you can
prove an inequality
i i haven't formalized it but i think
that should
i can imagine uh that could be true
i think something i think you should you
should probably be able to say
it is at least lambda over
uh as opposed to 1 minus lambda
something like 1 plus lambda something
like that
so it goes only a little bit down
but
cool um any other
question yes so so suppose that instead
of independence that you're working with
matchings do you think your techniques
can also bound like the the influence
matrix for for matchings like
beyond the uh beyond the threshold
somehow or uh yeah i mean i yeah
i think you can definitely do it um
i i mean i didn't write down like
formally or rigorously but i think it's
definitely doable you can do the same
correlation decay technique to bound
influences
you see and you think like
the city of lambda does not matter right
or uh
okay i mean okay that
do you mean matchings of all sizes of
perfect matchings
or uh
i mean if london is is large then then
it tends to produce close to perfect
matching
but i think it's referring to like
monomer dimer model
yeah uh yeah i'm not sure how to get uh
okay
yeah i'm not sure if you can get like
sort of uh
independent of lambda i i think it
should be possible but i didn't really
try i mean there's a problem with
perfect matching
it's like uh the chain is not even
connected
so you have to deal with all this crazy
near perfect matching stuff
i mean even considering one minus
epsilon approximate matchings
um if if if that influence matrix could
be bounded for
for for mono and dynam timer on those
and it's in its own right i think it's
it's it's a very interesting result
if you could get something
actually there is a structure on perfect
matchings which is connected
but it's not useful for sampling and it
is edmonds matching polytope
uh so so you know every every
every matching you can think of it as a
characteristic vector in whatever
um n dimensional space right and there
is an
edge between two matchings if
and only if uh there's a geometric edge
right so it's the famous edmonds
marching polytop and this has very very
strong expansion properties we had
shown this in the 80s which is yeah in
the ancient
ancient history uh and but
but but you know it's not useful for
sampling because the degrees
vary crazy and also
uh you cannot even uh simulate a walk on
it
you know like it's it's uh hard it's
it's uh
and be hard to find uh to find
if you're in a perfect match and to find
one of your neighbors
at random but but there is a very
promising structure up there
in uh n dimensional space with you know
which
which does have strong geometric
properties
and of course you know simulated we have
to go through
to these uh near perfect matchings if
there was a way to
have to walk through some other
structures that
you know to not mess up the whole
argument you know
i mean that might be might might be a
direction to explore
for generating you know perfect
matchings for
non-bipartite graphs i mean it's a very
wide gas and it's been going around
for a very long time but you know
who knows but it will not be through
near perfect matching that is that is
hopeless
why is it hopeless to approach general
graphs through near perfect matrix
oh because there are counter examples
where near perfect matchings are in the
middle
and they form a you know
i mean there's exponentially many and
they sit in the middle yeah but
but these techniques could i don't know
i mean this jsv type of
training okay okay well yeah okay it's
for people
to try but i mean i don't know no i i
don't know either but
but uh but but i know that that
many many people have tried um
for very long time to to you know
manipulate this near perfect matching
thing
you know but you know i i mean sure try
it but
but but is there a chain you're thinking
about
based on this palette based on the
edmonds politico
no that's a million dollar question
that's why i'm following all these talks
but but i mean at this point you know
everybody should know it's
that's the big price that sits on top of
this
right yeah
yeah well thanks anyway this is a very
useful workshop and this was a very
nice talk you cube thank you
thank you
all right any other questions
okay thanks again everybody thank you
convene tomorrow
yeah everyone bye